[Musique]
allez quelques résultats à vous proposer
on continue avec du football la 5e
journée de championnat de régionale 3
qui se déroulait ce dimanche
aubergenville s'inclinent 2 buts à 1
contre boulogne billancourt à
l'extérieur la cdb qui est le leader au
classement l équipe réserve des mureaux
elle a obtenu un match nul 1 partout sur
la pelouse de parisi et match nul
également pour trappe dans le derby
yvelinois face au pecq trappe qui perd
par conséquent elle sa première place de
régionale 3 et donc est deuxième un
match important dans deux semaines à
venir pour les trappistes qui reçoivent
le troisième à saint-ouen l'aumône et
dans le championnat de division 1
district la 6e journée plaisir
l'emportent à l'extérieur 2 à 1 contre
mantois et d'histoire également et sur
le même score mais à domicile pour guy
en cours contre hardricourt festival de
buts enfin mort bas 4 buts à 4 contre
sartrouville prochaines journées au
programme dans quinze jours on change de
sport en rugby avec plaisir décidément
n'y arrive pas dans le championnat de
fédérale 2 une nouvelle défaite dans la
6e journée drancy sur sa pelouse
elle devance les plaisirs ou à d'une
courte tête 27 à 23 les yvelinois
peuvent tout de même se consoler avec le
point du bonus défensif plaisir est
dernier au classement de fédérale 2
le basket avec la cinquième journée de
nationale 3 déconvenue à domicile pour
le fc trappes qui perd contre poitiers
score 77 à 68 les trappistes qui
joueront à nouveau dans quinze jours
enfin handball victoire de plaisir
plaisir après trois défaites d'affilée
succès 30 à 14 contre saint mandé dans
la cinquième journée de nationale 3
plaisir est entré à la sixième position
de cette nationale 3 de handball